Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to inside. Now we just
opened up this weird machine and somehow
this machine continues to lead us into
the labyrinth of this thing whatever it
is there's a toolbox there what does
that mean that means someone who needed
to use tools was here at some point for
for some reason that they built this thing
oh hi is this normal for you
is this normal everyday life for you
what are you filming
why are you filming it? am I part of a
big test
ah..
why are they not with- that is so
bizarre!
oh that's a- and FOUR there's another number!
04 it was 3
I saw 2s and this is 4. have I
seen 4s I don't know if I've seen
fours
this is so bizarre there's something to
this not to make a number pun but
there's something to this
ok, so what I need to do is I need to
make the water just enough that the door
opens which i think it does
over yonder way why was it so quiet in here?
can I open this? can I do something about this?
nah? okay. that's weird. so, maybe there's
always that all I didn't even notice
that the group of people in there but
that's no good
how did I not notice that how did I not
notice that
how did I not notice that what is wait
this different than what it was before
ah here we go I wouldn't notice that I
thought I was coming over here for no
reason who think that I needed a BOOOXX
from over here
okay, I'm getting in now.
sorry, oh boy what do I do? uhh..
AAHHHH
Don't do it! oh boy..
oh boy, oh boy, oh boy
this guy driving a forklift. a guy driving a forklift like
this is normal everyday occurrence. okay.
BOX
just randomly place box don't mind the
box
don't mind the box don't mind the box
you got your kid here?!
you murdered another kid in front of
your kid?! he's got a baseball cap and
everything
[Markiplier noises]
Sorry, I need to drink of water I apologize. The throat is a little raw.
Ooh, boy.
Are you done?!
Okay, I'm trusting you on this one.
I suppose you're done which means that
I'm gonna be able to use this to my
advantage so what I need to do is I need
to lower the water level
quote unquote raise the water level and
then move the box into a position where
it on that platform up there where I can properly utilize it.
AHH my legs
Okay. Lower..
So it's gonna flow right yonder there which is super weird I get it.
It's very weird. Ok, so I just need to put
it in a position where it's over this thing.
yeah what with the splash going up this all weird
The physics of this entire universe just
don't make sense anymore.
None of this universe makes any
sense anymore, but this is all just very nonsensical.
AHHH! Huh-blooff. Ok.
Good job, very smooth on the recovery
there.
So I need to go ALL the way up...
AAAND then back down...
right to dere... right to dere..
Okay and then we need to jump on
the box we need to get up on the boooox,
and everything will be a-okay. Boingity-boink, and boingity-boink. There we go!
And we're a winner! We're a winner, winner, winner, winner.
Hopefully we're going to get some
answers very soon.
I may just make this episode longer than the last ones, if it takes longer.
Oh. [Gasp] Do I get to go back to my buddy or are those laaaand mines- Waaater mines. Sorry.
I'm stupid
Can I still breathe under wa-wa? Eh, I'm not gonna' go down there.
Probably don't need to go down there first. Let me go up first and then I'll go down there.
Oh never mind I can't even go up. I
thought there was something--
Okay, nevermind I was, I was right on my first instinct which was to go down far.
So I need to do that.. Oooh, boy.
Hi. [Laughing] Hi. How is normal for you?
How is this normal? What are you
maintaining? What kind of panel needs
maintenance to hold these bodies in a weird stasis!? You bizarre bastards.
Can I hit this button on the way down?
I thinkI can hit this button on the way down..
[Sexual noises]
UHH!
Aww, I thought I had it I thought I had it but I didn't have it.
What does this do--? Woooooah! Okay that's not good.
Wh- Are we about t- UAGGH..
[Distressed noises] I'M SORRY [Panicked noises] I'M SORRY. [Whimpering]
[Distress]
[Louder distress]
[Fear grunt]
Why are you still following me? Why do you still worship me?
Have I been given the powers?! Eww, you're just weird blobs.
Ouueww, you're weird blobs I don't like that. There's another number four.
Ohhhh you're weird blobs.
Oh you're weird blobs. [Nervous laughing whimper] Eww.. Okay.. This is a thing.
Okay, then.
So. I need to push that button. I'm not even gonna bother to name you-!
You're blob one through nine. Jeezums.
AAAHA! Wrong way you stupid blobs...
Throw me uuup! [Squeaking]
Higher! Higher!!
Blegh! Higher you stupid- Blobs! Are you weak because you've been soaking in water for
so long that your bodies are just
nothing but mush?
Probably. Okay. so we need something to deal with that, but apparently you guys
aren't good enough because you can't
throw hard.
You need to learn to throw better. You'd think that the.. the heftier blobs
would be able to do this better but
maybe, wait, hang on.
Maybe I'm doing something wrong.
it's entirely possible that i'm doing
something wrong i just want to walk all
this way if it's not for nothing
there's a window over here but I don't
think that's going to actually help
anything
that's close better throw that you were
doing straight up that's for sure
No ok so this obviously isn't it if it
didn't work the first time it's not
gonna work a third time so there's gotta
be something else
a man the head on that one with the
bandages this is gross
so disgusting I mean you're all lovely
people blob one through nine ten eleven
i don't know how - you are so I must
have missed something fundamental over
here like this body Kings that body
oh it's still twitching oh it's
switching
oh that one's still twitching oh ok so
what happens if i use them to get the
water level up again Curt jungles
ok so the water level comes back down
I don't think that's enough for them to
throw in the world
the water came down a lot can you guys
throw me back
No ok so you can throw me back look look
look look look
but that might have done something else
that's why
ah here we go okay now i'm getting it
now I'm getting it
sorry sorry I'm not sorry you're
horrible horrible monstrosities and I
don't want to be around other following
me good
their leader they know they know what's
up so if I fall down to that sign with
the weird
war ii
let me just make sure there's nothing up
above no nothing above so maybe I'm
gonna hit on the way down
e I got it yeah
follow me thanks guys follow me your
weirdos
hello you want to join our party
apparently yes you do about you think I
was mopping
he's joining anyway so these guys have
been assigned a menial task they've been
programmed for some reason i have a
power I have a power to attract to
monstrosities
I don't think the other ones in what I
didn't know the ball well you all
survived but I had some trouble there
why didn't you warn me that there was a
pit coming up
I would have been very helpful to me ok
so you're gonna throw me across throw me
throw me throw me throw me that's been a
lot of faith and you don't get guy guys
guys guys
what the hell guys ok someone was
smoking you're like recently
oh they're running why are they running
what's happening what's happening out
there together just get away
why try to get something in my teeth now
you guys don't even know about my
personal problems but my thought is that
they're going to catch me
well they did thanks guys you guys are
not the best but I guess you guys are
now stuck here permanently but you guys
are all right thank you thank you guys
and gals if there are girls among you
oh oh ok
ok so i guess i'm not go that's not what
i thought was gonna happen but i guess
this is helpful
don't get squashed ok so a god damn it
now what
ok so they can't go that way they must
be able to go this way
it's gonna be a convoluted root of
follow the leader is it ok
wow that's as simple as that yet doofus
I come with me come with me follow me
follow me
take my hand follow me ok anyway I lived
it
they let it did it is asked is that
Vladimir again trailing up the rear
like a loser like a loser all these guys
are losers but they're my losers so I
keep him around for stuff I can't
believe that I've like grown accustomed
this this is this normal now for me
which is just as the water like hanging
around with these assholes is some
amount of wash it is somehow normal
whoa what is this what is this what is
this
I don't know what that says that's why
I'm asking what the chairs
it's so cool so cool i want to know I
want to know I want to be the very best
whoops come on don't feel guys but not
by have fun i'm going into the big
building that everyone else seems to be
sprinting and do
maybe I'm just trying to sprint to the
self-destruct button maybe I've actually
got a lot of malicious intent because i
can't just be running for my own
survival anymore
it was here recently I'm running from
malicious revenge purposes
someone's calling about a bad thing
something bad happened no one
oh gosh
so they do bleed that is a thing
what is this what is it look
hi who are you why are you here ok
what are you what are you doing okay bye
you don't pay me no mind
we owe you
hi don't mind me don't strangle me like
everybody else does
what are we all looking at what are we
all looking at here
what's happening
crash get out of the way ok don't mind
is it all right all right I'll take this
with me don't mind you guys do whatever
you're doing I don't know what you're
doing
I'll just take this damn i'm so confused
show me show me the mystery I want to
know
get on the thing god damn it get on the
thing in their life god damn it get on
the thing i want to know I want to know
the mystery I want to know what's going
on I don't know what's going on so
appropriately and what am I gonna have
no no I'm just going to get a better
vantage point maybe that's what i've
been doing this whole time I just been
running to get a view of whatever the
hell they've been looking at this whole
time could be bad news
what is it what is it what is it what is
so fascinating
what is so amazing what's so amazing i
want to know about the boo
oh man that's totally by design - that's
totally by design
it's meant to be like oh it's so good
everyone stop what they're doing forever
and ever and they just came to come
a-runnin look at this whatever the hell
it is you know and they're taunting me
there tantalizing me
it's so close right they're marking move
on you can know what jake to get you
would be good or no good ok
I think there's another thing to disarm
up here I'm following the yellow lines
and that usually leads to places where
that is the thing
maybe what is that
what's that sign mean oh oh this is the
end of the road always find it unlocked
all of them
oh I would have been here I would've
been able to open this thing I would
have been able to get a secret oh ok but
I was not nearly observant enough for
that man finally got three of them and
that makes sense
ok so for all you completionist out
there you've got an objective to
accomplish when you try this stuff here
so don't miss out on that there's
probably something really good and you
can find out what it is
I don't you look it up in the video but
i highly recommend getting it for
yourself
like when i play games like these i
cannot recommend playing it for yourself
enough
it's not that I can't recommend playing
it and you play it for yourself but it's
just man the developers put so much love
into some of these games and the so cool
that's so well made and they got so much
intrigue it's just amazing to see so
please support the developers in
whatever way you can
what is this oh I want to know
shuffle me where am I going ok turning
away from the big sphere or whatever it
is
one be smart about this baby
all right go down Bubba because
apparently been nothing but going down
this whole time I don't even know where
we escaped from me did we escape from
like an encampment of those people that
will be herded into things
this feels very end of the road yeah boy
yeah boy
up where ok that was one one thing that
I did the thing of don't know what I
don't know I feel the need to constantly
destroy everything around here is a whoo
what was that hello
what happened it's too strong
I go in no not yet okay so there's
another switch up here let me go flip
that since i'm such a mood to randomly
flip switches everywhere I go
ok fans are off now maybe I can go into
this thing maybe
no not in there at least down here
ok got quiet I mean inside and I want to
know what's inside the mystery box that
ship
ok so all right
ki tech conundrum it can't be solved its
in solvable it's unsolvable
it can't be done so i got to find a way
so there's got to be
I don't know how to how would you do
that
how did you do that why would you do
that how would you keep that open so you
go above can't exactly wedge anything in
there that's not part of the game
mechanics so it's not that's not what I
should be thinking there's got to be
something that I can't I in here before
I go in there arm
maybe I need to turn the fans back on
and maybe I need to just need to get
down there before warms up again
they can push me all the way down and
then it can instantly throw me back up
once i get to the right . okay there we
go
yeah that's the stuff oh yeah and we're
gonna go in three two escaped boink
whoo boy whoa
I'm hey kid I got naked
what the hell hi why did i lose my
clothes what are you doing there
what what you don't want me to do
something you don't want me to do
something
no no wait here let me get a better idea
of what the environment around here is
whoa ok oh uh uh haha
he our man
so do I have a choice here I don't know
what the hell this thing is
but it's obviously they don't want me to
pull the plug on it
what are you saying
no yeah no pointing they're pointing to
the thing why did they go in here where
they're waiting on me to do that so they
don't want me to pull this so i have a
choice
my god this
no no no this now
oh man
ok so considering my curiosity I'm a
more inclined to try this but then again
I don't know if there's a correct path
here or interpretive path here
either way I don't think anyone's gonna
be happy in there or it's a bowl the
same orifice mass god stop stop grabbing
me stop grabbing me you were not
assimilate me I don't know why I lost my
clothes but it's with that
well that wasn't good idea
oh god no oh oh man
brother yeah
ha ha ha ha ha
cheese oh my
yeah it is a pop on board haha well but
this did not turn out the way I thought
it would
oh man this could not have been this
kids objective the whole time
could it have in
the truth
the boy unless it once
you can't stop me now
Oh
cheeks and a hit
yeah good lord
Wow
hello can I simulate you guys you want
to be assimilated into the pile the come
with me
maybe this was maybe this was the kids
objective this whole time because he was
one of these things and that's why
that's why they tried to stop
maybe maybe that's why they were so
desperate to stop him because he was
trying to do this exact thing this whole
time
my assumption my assumption
yeah you might want to run buddy's whoa
never mind you're fine
I came to the wrong zip it's that guy
that guy lost his mind
so ya might my basic assumption has been
that this kid is human
when in reality this kid maybe
everything but human oh the blob
ok so i gotta go but the people are just
watching
really oh man
<operand> twenty </operand>
boy I'll take this
thank you I need this
I need it I need it don't need that day
on any that I don't know why I needed by
I needed
oh my grad yeah so like maybe that was
the thing like my assumption that
someone was in slaving the human race
when in reality
maybe that just wasn't it at all climb
out there
well that wasn't exactly a climb but
I'll take it
good job good job good job good job guys
good job guys are doing great
probably ready ready
shit
hey guys it's so good to see humans
again benefits its watching god
hello do you work here where are you
hi give me a hug everybody
oh no oh the book
let me wash this off a little bit I
don't flip upside down flip the bloody
side down on you doing here wash it off
good God well oh god there's still some
on there
gotta get that clean not good wall
remember yeah flip it over flip over
come on flip over flip flip for me
there we go that's our good flipper all
right we're out here right here your
weirdo habit David boink . up . okay can I
lift this
No
yeah
ok apparently that's not working all
right so what do I need to do
Oh obviously in the water there was
something else
that leg was twitching and there's
something over here
probably uh haha ok
I did not know that this was a thing man
we've got a collective intelligence and
it's all this kid he's been the
mastermind whoop missed
try again shit try one more time do a
little better
shit come on get it get it get it a
man this is so cool the adaptive
animation of this like I know it's
disgusting and horrible but also got
dammit don't don't don't be daaf come
on the adaptive animation is just really
cool like the technology is just really
honestly and truly impressive but that's
it's just nuts ok here we go
here we go he boink haha i'm taking my
stick with me
yeah doggies bottle wasn't so good
doggies you might not want to mess with
me i'm i'm just a little too much for
you at this point pretty sure anyway
that
yeah I made it well I don't think those
dogs can handle me
maybe the blast of like maybe the
blasting like energy pulse outside could
but this
I don't know what
BLEH
I lost some guys want to come back in
the pile
no you okay but wait what are you
guiding me? go left? aw thank you sir
oh maybe he was- oh I see what he was doing
eh eh eh oh good
ok I see what he's doing he was just
trying to get me to go left
yeah it's clear buddy oh it's clear
did you open it for me no not yet ok in a second though, in a second i'll be free
I'm just going to count to ten! one,
whoo, twelve. wheee ok thank you thank you sir
you're such a helpy helperton
Oh what if I don't want to
ok what's over here then, anything?
trying to hide something from me? okay
thank you. man these guys know what to do
apparently
is that an incineration
kill me kill me kill me, no?
ok oh I gotta throw it in ok ok, hang on
no apparently not okay taking this with
me wherever i may go
I honestly didn't expect there to be a
continuation of the puzzle with this
horrible monstrosity
I see
uh-huh
there we go got it on my way goodbye
people
uh-huh my home territory in the wall
haha her boy oh boy
where am I gonna go
blam
what am I supposed to- what am I
trying to burn myself
why would that be
no no that's not it I just toasted some
of my buddies yeah I didn't think that
would be it
I'm a graceful gazelle at this juncture
but there's something over there that i
need to burn
I guess I should have kept this box with
me huh
why though it just seems so bizarre that
this monstrosity has a logic to it
I mean obviously all controlled by the
kid yeah I get it I get it
if he is a kid stuff it in their stomach
oh now we've got a flaming back
oh no I must hurt buddy
damn it we got throw it over and catch
it
well this is some ridiculous bullshit
but i'll play by your game
you rogue ok it's a good thing i'm an
expert in this game that the business
hahaha ho
got it oh oh oh what up whoa
God it I know I know
on the best ok Tamil keep it alive keep
the flame alive and then I can light on
the fuel
it's like up over there man they are
sprinting to watch their so intrigued by
the horrible monstrosity
yeah this says is flammable ok it blew
okay but i'm just i'm helping me
well this engineering maintenance i got
it online we got a lot guys
I'm helping here to help
good boy okie dokie
where am I going I just want to know
where I'm going this is insanity
hello you let me up please
you're awfully nice if you did okay okay
what's he waiting for
yeah yeah we wanted so close but so far
okay so he's waiting on something oh
there was a truck over to the left I
didn't even realize that i should
realize it but I didn't do it so why was
everyone was running to watch for one
reason or another
so there must have been something to
that but I don't know
so there must have been something
happening with this amorphis blob that
everyone was coming to watch maybe the
blob got excited because it knew that
the the the player was coming you know
he knew that he was coming along it was
about to be time and he started to get
really active or something like that I
don't know if he's holding up the hook
so that I don't get up there like for
some reason here huh
okay got it Oh little
ah ok i'm a comin for you baby i'm a
comin for you
almost there give me one more try and
i'll be on the way a lot of stress on
those small arms
come on give me give me your goodness
give me the goods
come on give me the goods
give me the guise of right there
ok
all over there we go
god damn it huh I knew I was close
I just didn't have it quite right I was
very close but not not a hundred percent
close enough so i need to pull this now
and I should be able to get up and over
on this to Daddy
let me up let me over let me up
they had me over thank you hope need to
be farther up need to be farther over
okay
but now i got it now we're doing good I
don't know if we're still doing good i
don't know if we've ever been doing good
here but we're doing something I think
what through my office that the kid like
humanism human mannerisms
because like he flinched at the the
camera that was looking at him you know
it that sort of stuff
whoops oh that's not what i wanted and
how do i how do i activate this thing
yeah
ok so there's gotta be a way to activate
that he's pointing up at the sign is
like you're doing doing man
okay but there's got to be a tie there's
got to be a way to like turn it on maybe
I all I got to give it to him
oh maybe I got to give it to him he's
gonna give it back
who gave it do it give it back
do it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey yeah
ah shit god dammit i was on the right
drag it me get it get it man to man
thanks man thankfully just does whatever
the correct route is for but ok
get get get get get get get sugar camp
ok
made it through wow where am I now what
the hell is happening
oh is it this seems like a trap seems
like a trap
well it seems like a trap II our show
closes change or no did it happen
oh oh oh oh
ok
no all I can move
okay we're good they thought they had me
but they did not
so where am i going from here
what does that grab I grabbed onto
something over there
I'm not sure what I'm grabbing onto but
it's it's it's something
ok can I fit through here I don't know
what I'm grabbing okay i need to pull
from both sides
ok now i'm starting to see
ok so I'm just ripping this thing apart
because i feel like it
ah there we go okay now we got a way out
yes no maybe so oh come on that's
totally a way out yeah that is try to
fool me i know what it is ya little
these guys know I can breathe underwater
for some strange reason I don't know why
but i can and i would explain why the
needle affected the kid you know what I
mean
yeah some light up here
we're here we go yeah these guys didn't
plan very well for this shit
oh I almost missed you guys
vocalizations here like half laughing
half-crying going on in here
yeah
boy we almost out here
we almost out here maybe now
oh yeah
wait oh do I need to do that again
probably he keep keep whoa
oh gosh I'll try leaving quite a few
body parts behind now
whoa but it's rock of ages holy shit wow
wow
little beam of sunlight
I can't I can't do anything
I am i doing anything
is
what that
is that the end that can't be
wait
some examining oh my god that's the end
who want the Abu haha but something's
happening to that blob
it's like shrinking in on itself I think
I don't know what's happening
what happened how can that be here and
what sort of bizarre quest for freedom
was that
oh man i bet there's some questions
answered when you open that cube or
another key but this for you but wow
what in the world that last episode that
last act wall leash hit man that was
bizarre
oh boy oh boy oh boy
you know I'm thinking back I can't even
really remember what the end of limbo
was but man
on yeah well I don't like it was aware
man I still don't really get the name of
inside even though I went inside the
base and I don't know man that was made
in unity and it's hard to believe
considering how good like it was I mean
obviously have a bias against you need
the game because I played so many small
in the Oregon but it's just like wow it
was an experience like that's all I can
really describe as an experience it was
an a journey but I still have so many
unanswered questions I still don't know
why I was doing that I have theories i
have theories that kid wasn't really
human obviously he was one of those
things whatever they are and he was
trying to get back to that for some
reason and then he wanted that too is
scape somehow and got to a beach for a
little sunlight and that's good enough
it's like the only beam of sunlight
that's been in this entire game and it's
there and that's where went and I don't
know that symbolism to some extent that
i don't understand but this has been
inside
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you know what all this means are you
open the sphere for yourself let me know
down in the comments below
I am so but thank you everybody so much
for watching I do like doing series like
this i just don't often get a chance to
play a game like this you know
a good one an interesting one more more
interesting than good is important to me
in this one is so interesting and so
well made to like the art direction the
physics of it
the animations of it like all of it just
delightful bizarre but delightful
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching
I guess that is officially the end of it
and that is all for this week thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
bai bai!
OH !!
oh you miss me